All right, let's go next.
So many people holding, it's hard to know
where to go.
Let's try the five Oh six area code.
Who's calling today from five zero six.
Hello?
Is this me?
Yes, it is.
Who's this?
Oh, nice.
Ah, my name is Julian from Costa Rica.
Um, I had a question, uh, related to your
conversation with Sam Harris, so you had recently,
sure.
Uh, I was wondering if you were convinced
by, um, what Sam cleans is a distinction between
jihadists and white supremacists, uh, acting
based on their beliefs.
Um, for instance, in claiming that, uh, white
supremacists emerge Memorial alienating a
psychopathy, a sickle pathological conditions,
uh, instead of, uh, being warranted by, you
know, just uh, average day Joe's falling to
an attachment to uh, these kinds of ideological
beliefs and Assam claiming that one important
factor that makes this discrepancy on non
hypocritical is the other worldly.
You'll get everything you want after you die
factor.
And, uh, him claiming that there is some unknown
[inaudible] trolling, posting a propagandistic,
a narrative that white supremacists try to,
um, get the media spinning or something like
that.
But it seems that the same argument could
be made for the kind of, um, propaganda that
jihadists engage in.
Yeah, I was not convinced.
I think I got it.
I was not convinced by his argument.
I see, listen, when I hear a jihadist explain
what motivates them and I hear a white supremacist
explain what motivates them.
I presume the same amount of a genuine statement
from both of them, barring some particular
reason to think otherwise and no reason to
think otherwise has been presented.
Now that doesn't mean that you can't have
in a plurality of cases, different circumstances
that pushed someone over the edge to the point
at which they commit real-world violence.
But no, I did not find what Sam Harris said.
It didn't change my mind, so to speak.
Right.
Because it seemed to me that him saying, you
know, listen, um, it's not very known why
these white supremacists do what they do.
And then they're connected to sites like for
Chan and it's just all a troll and his mind
in some cases.
But I've never seen him make that claim for
jihadis, never seen him claim, uh, that Jihaadists
are potentially trolling and they're just
trying to get a, you know, us media crazy
because they hate, uh, Western powers so much.
Yeah.
And I called the, I mean, I called that as
I saw it, I said to him that I don't see that,
you know, I think the other thing is that
that's being ignored.
Imagine that it was proven that when a white
supremacist, uh, when, sorry, let me back
up.
Imagine that it was proven that when we hear
a claim that someone who committed a mass
violence action was a white supremacist and
we figured out, you know, what, they weren't
really motivated by, by white supremacy.
It was just convenient.
It would, or a troll, it would still be important
to answer the question, why are so many people
who aren't really white supremacists going
out there and committing violence and then
claiming that white supremacy was the explanation
like that would still be an incredibly relevant
and important thing to answer in society.
Right.
I agree.
And uh, I would, uh, really appreciate it
if you had another conversation with Sam and
try to clear the air on this topic.
I don't know that we need to clear the air.
I mean, it was, it was made clear during our
conversation that we didn't agree.
I don't know how soon he's gonna want to do
another interview with me, but that, that's,
I'm glad to have him back on in the future.
Alright.
Uh, thank you very much David.
You have a very capacious mind.
Love the show.
And uh, I was surprised to hear your Argentine
and accident.
I didn't discern it at all from you speaking
English.
Um, uh, it's pretty cool.
Now I have a bunch of Argentine and friends
down here, so I used to come one day.
Yeah, I would love to go to Costa Rica.
I heard that the place to go is, you'll, you'll
know the geography better than I would.
There is a peninsula on the Pacific side.
What's the name of that peninsula?
Um, I'm not sure I can, I can list some that,
that could potentially be it.
Ah, have you heard, um, maybe have somebody
in though, but [inaudible]
exactly.
It's the area that has done Marino and also
I think boon that Inez might be it and that
entire area, I have friends who go there regularly.
The thing is they've got to take two flights
to get there.
Like from Boston, you've got to go somewhere
and then to the Capitol and then you've got
to get an additional small planes.
So it's like all day, you know.
Right.
I would just caution you when you come, uh,
just be on the ALM.
Absolutely.
You won't really have this problem because
you speak Spanish, but uh, foreigners are
often times overcharged for, uh, the same
services, which is not a really unusual and
[inaudible]
foreign countries, but right.
Or in any country for that matter.
Right.
Well, certainly I will be negotiating in Spanish
with everybody.
Okay.
Thank you for the call.
Appreciate it.
Great to hear from you.
First call we've gotten from Costa Rica.
I love it now.